hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in one long passage in his worked upon
says-- Blaise Pascal very helpfully
outlines for us a dynamic between
self-love something that he thinks that
all of us feel to some degree and truth
to which it is as he says a verse and
comes to hate and in fact because of
this dynamic generates conditions in
which it becomes difficult for the
person to learn and acknowledge and act
upon the truth of themselves and and
indeed a much broader conception of
truth covering other things within
society the world their relationships
and if we go to the core of this the
fundamental problem as we're going to
see it is that self-love induces us to
not want to hear the truth about
ourselves so why is that the case if we
take a look at what he says he begins by
bringing up self-love which in French is
a more pulp not the other sort of love
of self but a love that is you might say
excessive or wrongly directed and then
he talks about what's translated in the
English as the ego and that makes
perfect sense because it's the mwah the
me the who I think I am right and he
says the nature of self love and of this
human ego is to love self only and
consider self only so when we talk about
somebody being egoistic we don't just
mean that they only value how things
affect them or that they privilege and
prioritize their own interests above
other people they have a sort of
shortening of vision they they really
only think upon themselves and the
reason why they prioritize themselves or
the reason why they're particularly
interested in
have to do with them and less interested
in how it affects other people is
because they are looking at themselves
they have the ego they have an image of
themselves in contemplation all the time
but it turns out unfortunately to
generally be a false image so he says
what is the human being going to do so
they want their self you know to be
better than it actually is
they want to think of themselves as
happy as capable as good as true as
beautiful he says he cannot prevent this
object that he loves that is himself he
is both subject and object in this from
being full of the translation here is
false and wants but the French is
actually a little bit harsher it's not
just false
you know deficits failures but actually
also unhappiness means they're in the
French if you really look at yourself
unless you're some sort of moral saint
or Paragon you will discover parts of
yourself that you're not happy with that
in fact make you unhappy to look at that
reflect unhappiness on your part and you
can frame it in terms of wants or needs
that are unsatisfied but it's really a
sort of unhappiness that you carry
around within yourself so he gives you a
bunch of examples here and there great
examples so let's look at each of them
he says he wants to be great and he sees
himself small how often is this the case
how many times do people need to think
of themselves as more important than
they are or as having a certain statute
even physically there are there are
people who try to tell you that they're
taller than they are or fitter than they
are so he goes out and he says he wants
to be happy
and he sees himself MS
durable there are so many people
particularly in this world that is now
permeated by social media and images who
are portraying for us the life that they
don't really have a life that is
primarily marked by happiness when
perhaps they're not happy much of the
time and this is part of the human
condition for POSCO he wants to be
perfect and sees himself full of
imperfections some people can't stand to
him any imperfections he wants to be the
object of love and esteem among other
people and he sees that his faults merit
only their hatred and contempt so many
people are not happy are not content
with how other people view them and that
indeed they make their own happiness or
their misery dependent on whether other
people like them or not or treat them
even as their their liked he says this
embarrassment in which he finds himself
in that's a problem this when we think
about embarrassment
it's literally to be trapped to be stuck
within something we think of it just as
a an emotion right that feels shame or
embarrassment or guilt or something like
that but it's really to be caught within
something that's both effective and
cognitive here so the embarrassment the
the problem that one is caught in leads
to a solution what's the solution well
it's to say that we're not going to put
up with that truth it's going to go
further than that and say that that
truth isn't truth that it's actually a
lie and that something else is the truth
and so Paschal tells us that self love
hates the truth about itself it hates to
hear it hates to see it hates to think
that it is
less great less happy less perfect than
it is and so it wants to destroy that
truth because that is what hatred is
really about it wants to see the thing
that is hated gone
that's how hatred is different than say
anger now can you destroy the truth yes
in a certain way you can but you can't
destroy it by making what currently is
the case not the case
can you you well you could you could
work on yourself you could change
yourself if you're overweight and you
want to lose weight where you can dye it
or you can exercise or you can find some
other way to do that if you want to be
better red you can set aside an hour
each day and read some books even if you
read them online
there's myriad things that one can do to
move one's self from a position where
any you know any any saying that you're
good would actually be false to a
position where it would in fact be true
but what can you do besides that an
easier thing to do is just to deny that
the truth is the truth so as Pascual
puts it self love wants to destroy the
truth in one's own knowledge and in the
knowledge of others so one's relation to
one's self and the entire social world
the world of one's relationships where
you find out who you are so he says here
we go he devotes all his attention this
is how it's made concrete to hiding his
faults both from others and from himself
and he cannot endure that others should
point them out to them or that they
should see them so this leads to as he's
going to say it at the very end of this
passage man being only disguise
falsehood and hypocrisy both in relation
to himself and others that is sort of an
extreme limit case but it gives you the
idea of how far this can go there are
some people whose
almost entire life is really a lie whose
business could be entirely paper fronts
who wanted them you think of themselves
and portray themselves as brave when
they are living on stolen valor we could
go on and on and on and whenever a
person does this they're always placing
themselves in what feels like a safer
condition but it's really a more
dangerous condition because the truth is
still out there
so what are you going to do about that
you cannot get everybody to accept the
lie or the concealment that you're
providing them and you may not in fact
be able to hide it from yourself forever
as well so he says this is really a bad
situation to be in
and he wants to stress that it's already
bad to have all sorts of faults but it's
even worse to deny that you have all
these sort of faults and you know this
is so for several reasons it makes you
unable to to work on those faults if you
wanted to change them but it also
generates this condition where you
constantly need to reaffirm that you
don't actually have any faults where you
need to say that how things are is not
actually what the case is and that takes
a lot of time energy and effort so this
is actually a bad situation he says it's
a great evil to be full of false but
it's a still greater evil to be full of
them and unwilling to recognize them why
that's adding yet another fault there
you're lying to yourself you're engaging
in what he calls a voluntary illusion
and he's got a few reflections here that
are worth thinking about he says we
don't like for others to deceive us
right I don't like if you lie to me or
you cheat on your taxes or you conceal
the fact that you know you've actually
got the solution to my problem or any
other sort of things we don't like to be
deceived by others he says we don't
think it's
err that they should be held in higher
esteem by us than they deserve so it's
not fair we should deceive them we're
doing something wrong to them by
demanding that they treat us as better
than we actually are and he says we it's
not fair that we should wish them to
esteem us more highly than we deserve
right we shouldn't deceive them so he
says what happens then when they
discover the imperfections well this is
where it gets very interesting so we
could ask ourselves this question here
what would be a better attitude to take
in this situation than the repressive
stuff it down lie about it keep trying
to maintain the self image keep trying
to preserve one's ego as we say we could
look at it this way the way that that
paschal sets out he he says when they
discover only the imperfections and
vices which we really have they don't do
anything wrong to us they're not
actually harming us they are not doing
some injustice to us they're not lying
about us even he says they actually are
doing as good why because they help to
free us of this evil this double evil of
having the faults and imperfections in
the first place and being stuck in this
state of denial where we have to pretend
like that's not the case we could take
that as an option we could look at it
that way and say when this person
criticizes me they're not just trying to
hurt me they're not trying to put me
down they're not trying to get my job
they're not trying to you know assert
power over me
they're actually trying to in some way
realize it or not help me out so he says
we shouldn't be angry at their knowing
our faults and even despising us but
it's right that they should know us for
who we are and should despise us if we
are contemptible if we are contemptible
the
- that is not to try to hide it or fight
them or get angry with them it's to
change who we are so that we are no
longer contemptible and this is what
Paschal says these are the feelings that
would arise in a heart full of equity
and justice isn't that a wonderful way
to say it these are the feelings oh
thanks for pointing that out
that would arise in a heart full of
equity and justice now there's two
things to say there one is that's not
our case for the most part right so as
he says then the second thing what must
we say of our own heart when we see it
in a wholly different disposition is it
not true that we hate truth and those
who tell it to us and that we like them
to be deceived in our favor and prefer
to be esteemed by them as being other
than what we are in fact he says the
proof of this makes me shudder when you
actually look at this when you stare the
lie in its face it is something that you
should have a an affective reaction
towards but there is this possible
better attitude that we could take that
we could steer ourselves towards but it
would take a massive effort on our part
and this indeed is what people who
engage in self transformation in the
realization of human nature attempt to
do now he goes on and he says that two
things there there's a corollary to this
other people don't actually want to tell
us the truth why not
because we've made it difficult for them
to tell us the truth without us engaging
in some sort of aggression or reprisals
or some other move some other hostility
against them
and he gives us some examples of this he
says he talks about a false delicacy
which makes those under the necessity of
approving others chew
whose so many windings and middle
courses to avoid offence they must
lessen our fault appear to excuse them
intersperse praises and evidence of love
and esteem why because we're not strong
enough to take people saying to us hey
buddy you're not as good as you think
you are
your playing isn't melodious your
actions over here are not harmonious
with the ideals you espouse your work
product isn't up to snuff you're not the
great lover you think you are you throw
a lot of money around but you're
actually poor because you've maxed out
your credit cards we go on and on and on
and on and on so people will soft-pedal
their criticism to us in part because
they don't want to incur our hostility
and you can think about how you do that
to other people as well so he says if
any have some interest in being loved by
us the reverse to render us a service
which they know to be disagreeable they
treat us as we wish to be treated as we
wish to be treated in accordance with
self-love right we hate the truth so
they hide the truth from us we desire
flattery they flatter us we like to be
deceived so they deceive us and there's
two things that follow from this that
are worth pointing out a little bit
earlier Pascal talked about there being
degrees of self-love and they're by
degrees in which we are embroiled with
in this dynamic he says there are
different degrees in the subversion of
truth but all may be said to have it in
some degree because it is inseparable
from self love it is part of the nature
of self love some people are just more
on top of it there is something that
makes it a little bit tougher for us to
recognize and to act upon this and that
is social hierarchy he says each degree
of good fortune which raises us in the
world removes us further from truth why
because it's harder to get people to be
straightforward and honest with us if
you're a rich person if you're a
powerful purse
if you enjoy immense social prestige as
do celebrities you actually have to work
to find people who will tell you things
as they really are because most people
have an interest in making sure they
stay on your good side
less so he says for people in lower
positions but that's still a problem he
says the evil is no doubt greater and
more common among the higher classes but
the lower are not exempt from it
because why there's always an advantage
in making men love us so human society
as he says is founded on mutual deceit
and he's got this telling line few
friendships would endure if each knew
what his friends said of him in his
absence although he then spoke in
sincerity and without passion it's very
tough to accept genuine criticism that's
on track and well informed from somebody
who we care about and that stems from
this issue of self love so we have to be
very careful if we want to know the
truth about things not only the truth
about ourselves and our qualities and
characteristics but all of our relations
with the rest of the world everything
that touches our ego if we allow this
self-love to take over because it will
cut us off from truth
you